I am very pleased to introduce my
sister-in-law Sarah Lund she'll be
coming in here in a second she has taken
great pains to create three pizzas with
very specific Pizza art oh wow you can
see something Sarah helped us out last
year she did incredible work using
marshmallow she's very artistic oh yeah
that's what she does for a living she's
a art artist and yeah she's terrific I
like her and so she's going to do she's
going to render some pizza art is what
you're saying and she's done this
professionally for Pizza Hut she's done
Pizza art very cool yeah all right so I
don't quite know what pizza art is I
don't either but we're about to I'm a
little bit I'm gonna say beguiled are
you yeah I've never been beguiled before
in my life are you Bewitched unbewitched
and bewildered I'm beside myself
um I'm behind the the times I am very
excited Sonia how you doing I'm all
right
yeah I'm fine
if you want a big hug I can't drink it
anymore you can't vomit into the solo
stove can I say one thing you are crying
and your tears are pure rum
yeah oh I gotta drink them
I'm excited check this out I just got a
notification on my phone there's a new
episode of Conan O'Brien needs a friend
oh there is yeah it's incredible Kelly
Clarkson is available oh wow very good
yeah that's a good one I like Kelly oh
here we go oh oh Sarah Lund everybody
Sarah thank you nice to see you again
hi uh if you want to talk you can stand
by the mic or you can just show off your
wares whatever you like Hello uh Sarah
you did an amazing job last year with
the s'mores art really incredible now
you're working with pizza which I think
is a much more difficult medium it is a
very difficult medium in fact uh it's
only gonna look nice this one time once
it goes in the oven it will become
bloated and distorted like my face after
50. yeah yeah
she agreed with you
thanks for uh jumping up and saying oh
no Conan you look amazing
helping us out here we also have my
beautiful wife Amanda and my beautiful
solo stove representative DG yeah
yes is it DJ or DG DG DG dude I thought
you said TJ but it's DG I did say DG I'd
like to correct you yeah thank you Sona
you said it right okay let's take a good
look at these These are incredible yeah
that's I think that's corally what do
you mean you think that's corally I
don't know you got ham hair you know
what I've often looked at your hair and
thought that looks like ham to me and
I've several times I've tried to bite it
yeah Sona you look beautiful in that oh
yeah I know Sarah thank you look at your
scallion earrings earring I just saw
that wow it's a scallion almost all
about that earring light it's a little
yeah you know the first two years that I
worked with Sona she used green onions
in her ears oh but it's more of a
superstitious thing and then let's see
the Conan uh this is Conan just post
surgery she's hair color drained from
his face
um and then you've uh surrounded me with
mushrooms not my favorite but you know
what I like the aesthetic I think I look
pretty
yeah it's all about the aesthetic and I
think you've done it you've really
captured my fear and my self-loathing
my uncertainty and uh all my genetic
frailties in one pizza and I think
you've done you've this is beautiful
work it really is yes very nice it's
really nice there thank you
this thought was where the other your
twin was we had to get rid of it oh what
happened to my twin
you're like separated my mother there's
a look there's family lore that I was a
malformed Conan I think you're the
malformed twins no I'm saying I'm the
malphite one the really good one went
off that's our
Ryan Reynolds I think uh I can't wait to
see these things get cooked and we all
get just blistered and mutilated
mine's going to be like a religious
experience where mine becomes even more
beautiful and that's when you all
realize that I am
maybe you should burn that one no oh
come on let's
I've always been nice to you Sona
that's with my pizza I didn't say to do
that I just suggested it be injected
into the crust oh okay well only this
crude Barbarian uh didn't follow my
orders yeah so I started with the cruel
Master himself and put Conan into the
900 degree oven yeah let's do it let's
go for it there for a while you guys
wanted to be there for seven days I hope
you sunscreened your pizza because
you're you're about to get blistered